from Newsweek of all sources I know
Republicans tie Hunter Biden to human
trafficking announce probe let me pause
right there they explicitly stated this
is an investigation of Joe Biden so
Newsweek they're talking about it but
they're trying to you know maybe the
goal with the article is to be like it's
Hunter not Joe right right but uh you
know I'll be specific they said they
were announcing an investigation into
Joe they didn't specifically say Joe
Biden was trafficking people although I
think he was with the illegal immigrants
yes he was well okay never mind he was
was this broken by Geek Squad or who did
it which one it just depends on the
source which which was it a computer
that was returned like who knows where
did they get the Intel uh actually I
think it was
um some Republicans in Tennessee who
filmed the children being trafficked on
U.S military planes around the country
by the bite Administration so oh right
no no I mean he literally was
trafficking children oh good for him